welcome to our christmas show holiday
it's the holiday season are we not
allowed to say merry christmas who would
join the club i would be inclusive yeah
you know that i got in trouble on the
set of roseanne because i said merry
christmas to the whole staff in a panic
what got
that evolved
when i worked at starbucks people would
yell at us they'd be like say merry
christmas like happy holidays like say
merry christmas who would say a customer
lots of customers this was around the
same time the elections were happening
because they were we had red cups
remember oh and they were like the devil
cups oh dear oh they'd have us write
like
different election quotes on it and
stuff and
if we didn't yell it out they'd be like
read my cup
i feel like mention
sometimes i'm hard on you
sometimes because i forget that you like
have seen the worst in human beings the
fact that you have a mirror
don't do that
the fact that you have worked at
starbucks and you you've just seen the
worst in people haven't you
yeah that's traumatic
someone telling you save the thing i
wrote on my cup yeah people used to
snapped us then what do you do they
would throw trash on the floor and we'd
be like hey there's a trash can over
there and they'd like you'll get it
never got it by the way didn't never
pick it up i mean look i'm i'm a real
grump before i have my coffee too
but
that's not acceptable yeah people don't
kind of say that they would snap at us
at one time gave a lady a free pastry
and she cussed us out wow because she
thought we were calling her poor was it
a scone oh no it was a blueberry muffin
it was me
okay this is the christmas show i know
it's getting off to a slow start don't
think i don't know that
just we're going to talk about some new
year's resolutions
and then we're going to read some uh
we're going to read some voicemails
i feel like
christmas makes me feel pressure around
the podcast because i feel like i have
to say something like meaningful or
profound or make it special but i feel
like not everyone's gonna listen on
christmas i don't wanna make it too
christmasy like i wanna make it like
kind of an evergreen episode but i'll
tell you and i do think talking about
new year's resolutions always feels a
little bit trite and
i don't think you should have to wait
till new year's to make a change in your
life if you want to should we say
should we go around and do some
resolutions no we shouldn't last because
new year's happens after the holidays
sure sure this is a christmas episode
okay so we asked you guys
to call in with some holiday drama like
conundrums that you needed advice with
drums these are your voices these are
your voicemails you called don't make
our new year's resolution be let's stop
listening to voicemail yes here we go
okay
hey whitney
um i just wanted to call because i
wanted some advice for when i bring my
boyfriend home for christmas for the
first time
i'm really nervous we're staying with my
parents
and
yeah just any advice would be much
appreciated love the show thanks bye
bringing your boyfriend home for
christmas i the problem is like this
question makes me have so many questions
bring him home nothing is more
embarrassing than being attracted to men
anyway so just bring him the first thing
i ask myself before i bring someone home
is do they all say
they're your boyfriend
you know what go home tell your parents
you're a lesbian and then if if they
react poorly wait a minute
[Laughter]
he's in the closet over here
um
i don't understand the point of bringing
home a boyfriend uh frankly i don't have
a home i don't encourage it if he needs
a place to stay that's a different story
i'm just saying if you're homeless if
you're dating someone homeless thumbs up
bring them home i just think this whole
like i need to bring this guy home that
i'm not even sure about to meet my
parents you're already too nervous like
the way you're talking about it makes me
think just wait until next year and do
it next year they're already so
stressful because you'll i don't like
this because you're already in an
anxious state and now that's gonna make
everybody else anxious and the whole
fucking christmas is gonna be you
bringing your guy home no one asked for
this right you're not sure about him yet
because you're already like i don't know
what to do right you called the podcast
you called us
and i guess i'm just saying there's no
rush to bring your guy home to your
family uh next one hey benton or emily
or whitney um my name is katie i'm
coming from virginia
looking for
uh fellow animal mom advice
um
basically uh me and
ex
split up
he promised to get me a dog if we moved
in together
while we were still together
we moved in together he got me a dog we
split up six months later
um of course i went out and got a dog
license for said dog um and we tried to
do
uh 50 50 custody you know just spoken
word custody amongst ourselves it wasn't
working out he was trying to use the dog
to control me so um one day he said he
wasn't going to give her back and i just
took my dog license and two cops and
showed up at his house and took her back
i got a freaking
sabina and a male from him try to get my
dog
oh my god
this is why you don't buy dogs listen
just
dress up someone dress that dog up like
a baby men never want babies
get a new dog yeah okay so here's the oh
no no no no no he only wants to don't
use stop talking he only wants the dog
so he can put it on tinder and get more
matches neither of you who have can
weigh in on this neither of you because
we don't know what dogs are neither of
you have three dogs no you don't you
have zero dogs okay
let's talk to the dogs
um okay so this is number one why you
never fucking buy dogs uh uh it's not
the only reason but so it's clear that
this guy bought her a dog and probably
spent two thousand dollars on some
fucking you know the dog that looks like
it was the beginning of the thriller
video because i can't walk because it's
so inbred and he's like but it's like
it's the one that's it's no such thing
the guy that invented the
hyperallergenic dog
made a statement and was like i'm sorry
i've made a dog that is like medically
impossible to treat and a health
nightmare so so he probably is like i
spent two thousand dollars on a fucking
inbred dog and is annoyed about the
money yet another reason to to rescue a
dog well she also said he bought the dog
to convince her to move in with him yeah
it already feels like he was trying to
control her from the beginning the only
thing to do is to date him again until
he gets bored of you
or burn his house down and then there's
nowhere for the dogs
yeah this guy is like
you know here's the thing when guys are
super obsessed with women like this
because it's like clearly he's just
sitting around all day plotting planning
on being with her i'm like i i just feel
like you need to just talk to him more
and like take him home for the whole
time
exactly like there's some i just am like
he just not that you're not the most
lovely effervescent charming smart
engaging
katie i'm just saying katie just there
is something to be said to be like yeah
let's hang out and just spend the whole
day just being super annoying right or
talk to him about getting married yeah
ask him if he like how many kids he
wants say he has big hands he'd make
such a good father
give him the dog and he'll probably give
a bag no what do not give anyone your
dog sorry that is horrible advice don't
give anyone your dog
i'm so curious what kind of dog because
i do know there was a guy that i was
kind of hanging out with who
inherited a dog in a breakup that's like
the ultimate leaving your earrings at a
guy's house to come back and get them
the next day correct which i've never
done
i only ever have one hearing but also
i've never left a earrings at a guy's
house it's an excuse to come the next
day just the kid i just take a shit
and it doesn't flush it's time to go
back they know who's boss
[Laughter]
every woman i think that i know at least
my circle of friends are cool has taken
a dump in a guy's bathroom it's usually
new york because of the plumbing you
flush it doesn't go down it doesn't go
down and you had to scoop it out the
dixie cup throw it out the window
broadway i i never walk on the sidewalk
sunday mornings in new york city yeah
because i know i owe someone a big
apology
okay next voice the guy that you slept
with
him and the one that got hit by my turd
hi whitney um i'm a big fan my name is
astrid um i heard you guys like begging
for like not creepy people to call so hi
i'm i don't think i'm crazy um
yeah really good podcast oh my god thank
you um
and oh right thanksgiving
okay
okay thanks again i've been dating this
um
person
like non-binary person for like um
like almost two years like 18 months and
like we were really getting into it and
stuff and i had this big accident like a
building fell on me it's more
experienced and actually like
now did the building identify as falling
on you or did it identify as falling
forward what do you mean a building fell
on her like a dollhouse that's the only
detail you get
that's enough
i need more so you don't know this but
this is actually the wicked witch of the
east calling it
so when the house fell on them
do you remember that they now identify
as the wicked witch of the west
i don't think i understand a building
fell on her
that's all
on them yes it must have been that bad
did they send this on 9 12.
when was this voicemail recorded i was
curious september 12 2000
[Applause]
okay
in the hospital and took care of my dog
and like really helped me
and then and this that was like august
september okay and so now it's november
um also october whatever she built
so then she she was like come to
thanksgiving with my family and this was
like last week and then like two days
later
dumped me
nothing had changed nothing had changed
jumped me deposit apropos not except for
that building had your appearance
changed like at all from the building
falling on i mean it's harder to date
someone's like getting crushed on
nothing changed
except a building had fallen on me
and who hasn't that happened to
and frankly that's all i don't want to
talk about so she wants to know why
she would have been broken up with is
essentially the rest of the message uh
maybe because you're bad luck no i think
are you an omen it's no i think it's
more that you just like blow past really
important pieces of information and
the person you're with needs more intel
astrid if you could call us back and
explain about the building that we would
really i have some follow-up questions
when someone leaves you it's it's
they're doing you a favor i know it
doesn't seem like now especially in your
time of need right especially when
you're trying to build building you're
building your life
[Music]
especially when your life is one big
lincoln log yeah okay
yeah 100 you're welcome okay hi whitney
my name is christina and i have a
holiday
toxic
drama slash question for you okay so my
sister has uh
a little dog
that goes with her everywhere and she
loves this dog i love this dog everyone
loves the dog
except for my step dad
so he has created a rule that the dog is
not allowed
in the house
and
we're happy to have time with it because
we want to bring the dog home for the
holidays we want to you know have him
there with us and celebrate with us
but my stepdad pretty clearly stated he
doesn't want the dog in the house can we
stop him yeah
i don't need to hear anything else he
came first the dad or the dog i'm so
sorry
step dads have absolutely no rights
whatsoever
to make rules to have sex with the
children in the house to do fucking
anything a step dad if you're walking
into this situation you have absolutely
no power stop pretending that you do
you're embarrassing yourself nobody
respects you nobody likes you they know
you're the second choice and we're all
just like walking on eggshells around
your ego
stop trying to get a dog involved in
this grow the fuck up instead of just
zero dog find something compromise if
you in and say what your problem is if
you're like i just don't want to fucking
eating the ham during dinner neither do
i that's fucking gross be like during
dinner can the dogs stay in the bedroom
like come up with something more
specific than just no no no yeah cause
you just looked down
you look dumb compromised so everybody's
a little bit miserable yes that's what
the holidays is about that's actually
true um all right well i think you're
pretty clear on what to do right
christina
happy holidays
hey whitney and everyone it's really
good for you paul
benton emily grace everyone
um yeah i saw your post about um
calling in with holiday conundrums
so i've always been the type of person
who
buys
people really nice thoughtful gifts
and i think my whole life probably as i
never
really get the same in return from
friends and it's not that i expect it
like is this just me being codependent
i'm like
here's a gift about that one thing he
told me three years ago
and he said you really like it and then
in return i get like a candle hmm i
agree this is i feel this way but gives
a lot
i think i put a lot of thought into
gifts too and i think that some gifts
are some people are just really good at
gifts and if you listen to people and
you talk to them and you care about them
and you know about their hobbies and
their interests gifts are a lot easier
some people just think a gift is nice
right right it's not their life and you
have to just be okay with that because
you can't be like hey um this gift sucks
because
you know then you're just really in
you're rude
do you want to hear my response or not
yes well you're a re-gifter so we know
your response
no i just like look i wrote a lenny
letter about this rest in peace lena
dunham
i know lena dunham's uh i wrote a whole
thing about this so
codependence i've talked about on this
podcast at length it's when we sort of
obsess over someone else's um
discomfort we can only define ourselves
through being useful productive um to
someone else uh we
give gifts with strings attached
and with expectations and that is you
know as someone that loves giving gifts
is someone that loves over giving that
used to way over give and uh you know i
remember going to a 12-step meeting once
it was a double winners meeting which
means you qualify as an addict and alana
was at a friend of mine's rehab on
christmas and this woman was sharing and
she goes my new year's resolution this
year every year i give half as many
gifts as i i gave the year before
because my gifts come with strings
attached and expectations i put all this
time and energy into this gift i got you
this and then you just got me this
fucking gift card and now i feel
victimized so a lot of what we do in
codependents is we set ourselves up to
feel like shit and feel victimized
because it's familiar to us and it's not
fair so if someone does this amazing
thing for you
and then you're like here i got this
candle and they're like but i did this
it's like i didn't ask you to do that
right and you're talking about our
relationship with and i didn't want that
i want you and you define yourself
through your uh productivity and the
gifts you give someone and what you're
basically saying is i'm not enough
and you're shallow do you know what i'm
saying right yeah and our relationship i
know just let me is predicated on things
and stuff and instead of just like
hanging out with you and having a great
lunch with you right i put all this time
and energy into this because of what
happened in my childhood it has nothing
to do with you yeah and i put all this
pressure on you to receive it the way i
wanted you to receive it so when you
give someone a gift it's not a gift if
it's like you better say thank you every
day and love it so much that's why i
don't like opening gifts in front of
people because i have enough codependent
people in my life still as someone that
was a codependent that when someone
gives me a gift i don't i'm too afraid
to open it because i'm like i'm not
gonna have the reaction they need me to
have
you know and i don't
any more
i i i do gifts like i have to be very
careful about the gifting i do because i
i really will slip into that i will give
too much and then like well i gave them
that gift and they didn't call me back
and then show up to my birthday and i'm
like oh there's a scorecard the intent
was behind the gift and also gifts it
means different things to different
people like i put a lot of thought into
gifts i my dad mentioned something six
months ago and i get it for him yeah i
like you i like to do how i show my dad
i love him that's not how he shows me he
loves me you need to do less
yeah that's the real answer you should
do if somebody is constantly uh
delivering for you or disappointing you
you need to do less so only get 50 in
relationships it's just that the
holidays are hard enough life is a
nightmare you not getting the gift you
hoped they wanted to give you is not the
biggest problem in in the world and it
doesn't mean that they value you less or
love you less it means that they don't
value gift giving the way you okay next
up next up
so i have a myriad of holiday conundrums
yeah so when i was in high school my
cousin kidnapped my grandmother from a
nursing home
um
when i was in high school my
mother kidnapped my grandmother from the
nursing home at least she didn't get run
over by a reindeer
got her good
because
like we were gonna sell her house and he
was living there
um you know it's like a ford said
nursing home yeah
anyway he kidnapped her and like
you know police got involved and like
guns were waved and
um we haven't spoken to him since her
death because you know
crazy
um
but yeah my other aunt just like
recently reached out was like would you
and your siblings be willing to meet him
over christmas for like dinner or drinks
or whatever
so she is there no limit to how batshit
crazy family members are in terms of
what they ask in terms of could you guys
just talk yeah just because you're
family with somebody doesn't mean you
ever have to speak to them again good
point what's the question i mean oh the
question was should she meet up with her
cousin of course not next one this is
our last one
last voicemail
is it from
imagine
me and everybody at the show this is
zach from iowa i was just calling to get
some advice
my wife and i have been separated for
just about a year and i was wondering
would it be appropriate or not to get
her christmas present i feel like i
should give her at least something
even though we don't talk very often
um let me know your thoughts thanks bye
no
leave her alone zach are you single
but if you want to give someone a gift
we do love gifts um
benton only likes thoughtful ones that's
true he's separated from his wife and he
wants to get her a gift
[Music]
that's so sweet she's like should i come
on in her mouth yeah should i give her
her new boyfriend should i give her a
gift of my
did you see him trying to trick us up by
talking really sweet he was like so am i
in my wife have been divorced he sounds
hot no he said separated not all
straight guys are bad he seems very
saying that i just said what he said
he
here's the deal okay buying a gift for
your ex i no it just feels guilt-driven
to me it feels obligatory it feels
anything that's driven by guilt or fear
just don't do it it also depends on the
situation it's like are you trying to
get her back don't don't buy her
something it's just going to make things
confusing and
you're going to spend money on her it's
going to confuse her it's going to
confuse you
wrap up your alimony check
i'm trying to think yeah don't get your
ex a gift just leave her alone i think
the best thing you can do is leave her
alone so that you could both move on
because you're just creating more
attachments and either way if she's
still into you it's going to lead her on
and if she's not into you you're going
to annoy her so there's no win there's
no good outcome so one of the the best
roles that i i've gleaned is like walk
through how your best case scenario know
what you want out of it right so that
you're not in this vague
like disappointment setting yourself up
to lose so true so that you know if you
hit the mark or not so i'm saying so if
you do do it
have a scenario so that you're not like
well that didn't go high planned i
didn't fucking plan everything right
have a scenario and then realize it's
going to be worse and then don't do it
what's the best gift you've ever gotten
emily um best gift i've ever gotten my
first boyfriend in college the one that
called me the wrong name when i lost my
virginity sure
what was the name
he called me claire
but my name's emily
um
you don't not look like that are you
true what i've said you have big clear
energy i got big
i got big clarity so what kind of guy
calls out any name in bed well he was
like i love you mid-thrust claire first
thrust what if he was gonna call you a
cunt no he was click oh you know why he
might have been calling you a cunt maybe
he said i love you maybe he said i love
you and i have clarity about it now
it's awesome
it's all so clear what if he was like i
love you clarice and he was into eating
women oh my god maybe that was john is
that what that was john of course um
john not all john's are bad
john got me a um
a beautiful jewelry box like with my
jewelry claire's name on it so for when
other guys get you jewelry put it in
here wow you've managed to ruin the
night
she was waiting what's the nice gift you
ever had a fucking here's a jewelry box
here's the thing to put other jewelry
you're right and he never got me jewelry
did have a little ballerina spinning
around in it no it had my name on it but
oh that is really nice yeah i mean that
is i like toy boxes
wow that's dark we now
take a break in this relentless joy with
probably some passive aggressive barbs
uh that could be jokes or could be real
uh to to talk about
someone that helps us
better than anyone else can
we're going to talk about better help
and you know we are starting with santa
oh yeah no no santa only comes once a
year we need we need to come more than
that
whenever you need whenever you need it
okay text anytime santa's like all
caught up on other people your better
help person is with you and just
you you can start communicating in under
48. and if you need someone to help you
with your naughty or nice list i
recommend a better help counselor
because they're going to be like that
wasn't naughty you just did the best you
could with the tools you had nice to
yourself no that wasn't naughty listen
here's what we need to let them know
this is really cool we did this okay
oh yeah at the show
you guys the fans helped us with this ad
which oh on tour we like to we like to
put you guys to work you come from a
comedy show to run in seattle seattle
you guys really helped us out with this
so here's a fun video of me reading you
about better help and the audience
filling in the blank
[Music]
[Applause]
is there something interfering with your
happiness or preventing you from
achieving your goals then you should go
to
[Music]
[Applause]
your health assesses your needs and
we'll match you with your own licensed
professional therapist who's that
[Applause]
it's not a crisis
[Music]
[Applause]
wow
y'all really did that it takes a very
better helped person to ask their fans
who have paid money
to see them and to not have to work
to get to work and help us with our ads
they actually are now all asking for a
piece of whatever better help paid us
for the ad and honestly i respect that
this podcast is sponsored by better
helping good for you listeners get 10
off their first month at betterhelp.com
whitney go quick honestly we shouldn't
because let's be honest we're too
confident
not me
witty what what's the bravest thing
you've ever done your whole life
hire you too
okay
do you have a photo of that what are
yeah we have a selfie in zany's
nashville that's so that you hired me
cool cool yeah it might have i was yes i
did you were like i'm a fan i was like
what would you do
if you could go to the future and ask
your future self one question since when
are you interested in anything about me
either of you okay
since one of you guys
had a question about me okay um
if i could go to the future and tell and
these are very thoughtful questions i
know but you know what i just realized i
don't even need to take notes about this
because of story worth and you don't
want to know the answer right i can't
even answer it no i'd rather wait in a
year when it comes in the book
wait what explain this to me this
holiday season i want to give a gift to
my loved ones it makes them feel special
and unique just like i don't like your
hair i don't no one let me finish any of
my answers just like the relationship we
share that's why i'm giving everyone i
care about story work now what was the
question story more than an online
service that helps you and your loved
ones preserve pressure memories and
stories for years to come it's
thoughtful and meaningful it's a gift
that connects you to those who matter
most you know what it is every week
story worth emails you and your
relatives and your friends thought
provoking questions of your choice from
their vast pood of possible options each
unique prompt asks questions you've
never thought to ask and thank god they
put it in a book one year if someone
only talks in a speech impediment
impediments you can't even understand
the story thank god it's all written out
for you in a book so you never have to
see them again well after one year story
worth will compile all your loved ones
stories including including photos into
a beautiful keepsake book that you'll be
able to share and revisit for
generations to come which is better than
my idea of compiling all of our ashes
together
yeah and um
with story worth i'm giving those that i
love the most a thoughtful personal gift
from the heart
preserving their memories and their
stories for years to come it's weird
because you probably have many stories
left do you
go to story worth
do you want me to answer that or no
slash whitney these aren't rhetorical
questions by the way that's only in this
dynamic do you not get to actually tell
the story but mostly where did we learn
that go to storyworth.com
whitney and save teen doodlers on your
first purchase that's storyworth.com
to save ten dollars on your first
purchase coming up we are our comedians
and we are going to be in your city
before we get back to the christmas show
come see us january 7th san diego at the
balboa theater january 8th i'll be in
salt lake city kingsbury hall how
romantic uh july 15th i'm gonna be in
las vegas january 15th would i say july
that's january 15th i'll be in las vegas
but when you're in vegas like you don't
know what month it is that's true you
know what i'm saying it always you don't
know where it always feels like july i
think that's why i i conflated those
at the wynn theater january 28th we'll
be in nashville tennessee polk theater
we're gonna also come in early and do
some fun stuff around nashville so send
us ideas february uh third i'll be in
charlotte at the night theater february
4th charleston south carolina wilmington
delaware gosh we are coming to your city
i love you uh and this is a christmas
episode where we're supposed to be um
making you laugh and feel joy and not
have to remember logistics so good bye
christmas queen
do we have new year's resolutions or is
this too toxic
i i don't think it's toxic i can make up
one right now no
no i'm going i can too well okay so i
want to keep on the david sinclair
regimen that i've been on okay dr david
sinclair who's coming on again i think
in january um author of lifespan
the great master of genetics at harvard
i guess
um resveratrol nad and nmn are the three
things that he says to take and what are
those are pills those are pills they are
vitamins uh resveratrol is like from the
skin of a grape and a man um
animen and what did i just say nad can
you can you guys
just eat m m's all day that's me uh and
it is something about the mitochondria
whatever we did a whole episode on it
can you get can anyone get them anywhere
anyone get it anywhere it does not
matter what the brand is he doesn't have
a brand and then b12 and um
and then metformin i am taking that is
by prescription it does limit the
ability to make muscle which i'm trying
to build more of but whatever why do you
take that it's stuck okay so metformin
is a uh a prescription that was uh in
testing given to people with diabetes to
manage their blood sugar levels and it
makes it so that you don't process sugar
the same way
helps you lose weight makes your um like
uh skin thicker because they're not
producing sugar the same way
a lot do you take metformin a lot of
people
how do you get less cancer because
cancer eats sugar it's a prescription if
you just say i want metformin i'm
worried about cancer i have cancer in my
family i have uh uh you know like sort
of my family keeps weight on just going
and go i'm so sweet i didn't even have
four and i'm full of sugar yeah exactly
sugar
a lot of people say the metformin at
some point will be like required by
insurance companies because that's how
beneficial it is
i then my peptides which i inject i'm
doing a pretty good job benton saw me uh
the other day bringing on the road in a
daily harvest
um
salad love you daily harvest and put it
in a freezer which these are shots
called peptides which i take
um i'm trying to take care of myself
because i spent a lot of time not
sleeping and um
aging myself on
uh chasing around
drug addicts um
in my 20s
and
i want to stretch
more
you can't sitting is the new smoking
sitting is they need you you've got to
stress i've known that for five years
and we're all still if you're not
stretching what are you doing
you're you hate
if you're not stretching you hate
yourself and i hated myself long before
this stretch is someone that you're not
stretching at all you look at me in the
airport stretching and you're just like
yeah i'm not stretching seriously i'm
not doing that not doing not even at
home like alone in your room oh yeah
my resolution is um to be more
comfortable with the amount of space i
take up in this world
yeah it's enough already
uh to not let my low self-esteem be
someone else's problem why do you still
have low self-esteem
based on what uh the two people that
hate everyone love you me and lorne
michaels
how could your self-esteem be low
she's worked with me and lorne michaels
two people whose approval is impossible
to get what more do you need my other
new year's resolution is to
stop waiting for life and to like
do sure life i've been waiting a long
time for someone to when's it gonna
start and it's like guess what bitch
we're about to share
not insulted at all so what when
like you're like i work for whitney i'm
like when's life gonna start no i don't
i understand what you're saying i feel
that way that means like building a home
sure like dating it's on you um yeah
that's what i mean being proactive
sure waiting for something to fall on
your lap instead of that being proactive
a thousand percent has nothing to do
with
work that's like
all other aspects how can you do that in
a uh actionable way
um
god
like build a real life here yeah like
get on
a dating app like make friends like
show up i have friends i have friends
what dating is really good friends just
went off like 14 times but i don't ever
check like i need to engage in it that's
psychotic can i see oh sure sure i'll do
your uh hinge while you um
formulate a response um
yeah you might
because i think this is common where
people like you know
i do this too where i'm like on a dating
app to feel like i'm participating but
i'm kind of not really right
yeah your photo is excellent on your
dating what is this farmer's only oh
hinge nobody likes those pictures i
mentioned men my neighborhood downtown
santa monica that's a red flag okay age
range oh you want 30 to 42 i like that
maximum distance 14 miles what are you
fucking marie antoinette you can't drive
more than 15 miles to meet someone but
then i'm ending up in okay we're moving
it to 30. san clemente okay wow barely i
barely have a car i'm moving it to 36.
and whose fault is that
maximum distance british models
ethnicity open to all
that is
oh good honestly a surprise
honestly a surprise family plan what
family plans open to all another
surprise wait what why drinking open to
all wow oh marijuana oh yeah drugs open
to all you want to drink orange juice
you want to drink water you want to
drink soda how do i go to your um like
matches well i gave them to you to pay
no okay sorry it's telling me you asked
me if i'm gonna learn more and i don't
you've already learned enough
all right what are your new year's
resolutions um i wanna disassociate more
so you're practicing now yeah i want to
stop uh putting energy and time into
things that
don't put energy and time into me that's
a great resolution and i just just i
already hear from
well i'm just saying a lot of times like
i think that sensitive people i don't
mean to like if you're not like i
consider myself a sense of person the
biggest uh like sort of like business
move i ever made was stopping giving
energy to things that didn't need my
energy and just going like this isn't
personal it's not about me i'm just
gonna save my bandwidth
and let this play out
and like uh have an economy of my energy
because the only thing i have to offer
the world is my energy and if i spend it
on all this stuff that doesn't need it
right like i need to conserve it maybe
that's what you're saying maybe it's not
so that's mine that's a really good one
like what what specifically
this conversation
what do you mean but it's like this
conversation like i'm done spending time
i'm done on this conversation period the
end wait are we done talking about if
you're going to date somebody because i
really liked that no we're talking about
your new year's resolution well those
are them i think those are only two i'm
trying to think if i have any other ones
dating people is just practice though
you can also date people that aren't the
one i do it all the time
no
yeah i i'm i'm at a i'm at a uh
i don't know where to meet them i don't
i don't know
i don't like i don't like that's fair
apps and i and i don't know where to
meet them and why don't you like apps
i think a lot of people relate to that
but i issue a kind maybe a personal
question do you feel
like you're going to meet someone at
some point
yeah i think i'll be fine i think i'm
going to meet someone i think i'm going
to be
where blissfully happy where
specifically i have no idea i have never
gotten anything i wanted had i not i'm
just really counting envisioned it first
i'm really counting on it working out
i'm counting on being successful i'm
counting on but you're kind of
passionate
i think that's that's a big part of it i
don't know why i have no data to prove
that that will happen but do you have
everything you want now i think i've
gotten um
what i've wanted
eventually
yeah but what if you want it now
well i don't think you're ready for
everything you want now
interesting i see you going back and
forth to going like i'm gonna let the
universe decide for me and if i'm just
like i feel like you have
conflicting tools that are so
brilliant going like i'm going to get
everything i want i'm going to detach
and have faith
but then i just sometimes we use that as
a way to justify not being proactive yes
a hundred percent because like if
someone can't find you how are they
gonna find you right but yeah yeah but
every guy i know is looking for someone
like you but where are they gonna find
you well here's the thing i've always
felt very taken care of by the universe
or whatever that means right and so when
when i was okay so for example i'm
i moved home accidentally for a year
during covet i was working on a show for
hbo it got cancelled i moved home that
wasn't mine right no i this was in
february of 2020 and i um
i was like i'm just going home for a
couple weeks while we flatten the curve
and then the curve turned whatever and i
actually just circle get my butt to be
flatter
i accidentally moved home lived with my
sister and with my mom and dad and then
i was like what am i doing like i kept
my apartment in la but i have no idea
what i'm doing and then you randomly
called me and you were like do you want
to run my podcast and i was so weird
yeah
like that shit just always happens to me
and i regret it every day
you're like i regret this oh everything
i thought you were saying no no no no um
yeah like i just i know it sounds like
ferris bueller irresponsible
it's i do think that like it's like you
gravitate what you want and what you
deserve and i think patience is really
important but i do think with
you know for me like you had laid down
the groundwork to where i trusted you so
much and relied on you so much into your
character but like in terms of if you
want a partner i'm not saying go out and
chase a bunch of fucking losers i'm just
saying like i don't think there's anyone
out here there who necessarily was like
she's the one she's putting on this
groundwork i already trust her like
that's what you did with me though i
mean you know it's slightly different
with someone
for me like i i think i have ended up
with a lot of people amazing i don't
look at relationships as like this needs
to be forever
i'm very much in the camp of like if i
meet someone and we're together for
three years and i meet someone else and
we're together for four years and
someone else or the other six months
like that's a success for me i no longer
go like i'm going to meet someone and be
with them forever if it's not in a
platonic capacity because i don't know
who i'm going to be next year and like i
can't meet someone today
and go next year we're still going to be
soul mates because i might be a
completely different person because i'm
still growing like i'm finally at a
place in my life where if i get new
information i'm going to
change my mind right and be different
and if i learn a new way to take care of
myself i'm going to adapt to it instead
of go like i'm going to stay
crazy so for me anyone that's attracted
to me today hopefully i'm a different
person in here there are a ton of people
that are like in a year i'll also change
what i need from you right right or i'll
like this new person totally i'm super
open to the idea that like i'm hoping to
be a different person a year and if you
want a different person you're in a year
great you get to cheat on someone else
with the person you're with because i'm
going to be a totally different person
different hair color different body
different personality yeah totally so
like for me i'm not willing to stay
stagnant emotionally mentally or
physically in order to yeah so unless
someone is willing to grow with me or be
into
a new iteration of me every year like or
six months even
i i'm i'm really open to the idea that
it changes that it's not for me i also
think that soul mates can come in
different like
bodies
men women
animals yeah
friends like i get so much of my
emotional needs met from my
quote-unquote platonic friends
that
you know the person that would be my
person has to like
be okay with not um
getting everything from me because i get
so much from other people
so so i i'm fine with different
iterations of it like yeah i'm the same
way with agencies production companies
anything i'm like like assistance
anything i'm like we should be together
for like two years yeah and then evolve
into something else and i'm like i'm
honestly like i'm okay with being alone
like i don't mind it like i do my own
thing like i
i don't know i'm super happy alone but i
don't think i'm ever alone i have like
i have so many people that don't have
sex with me they give me so much um
fulfillment yeah and i like i get more
excited about like the butterflies and
the chase and the initial things
that you're like when i'm in it i'm like
why did i when i hadn't had a boyfriend
so long and then when i did have a
boyfriend and and i was like well if i
just have a boyfriend everything's gonna
be fixed
and then i had one and it wasn't at all
like it kind of was worse
and so i'm kind of like i mean if i
don't but which is why i think it's
important to just put out their stuff
like this because they will attract the
right people i spent so much time being
like and i want a relationship and i
want to have kids yeah 29 and then i was
attracting a person that wanted all that
and i was like i have this yeah but i
can't stop smoking eating edibles and
checking out so
obviously there's a dissonance here like
there's what i think i am supposed to
have in order to be approved of by
the algorithm right and then there's the
thing that actually makes me feel good
it's like right and i don't necessarily
know what that is i'll note when i see
it but i do think it's important to just
like lift that socially constructed
right thing of like i need to spend more
time you think about this more time
being upset about that i think about
this all the time really it's part of my
job
as a comedian think about this
interesting well i as a community i
remember very vividly like so clearly
being like 13 being in school and just
being like oh that's not going to happen
for me and just like washing my hands of
it
good for you but how so i don't know i
remember i remember i mean i remember
very vividly like we were talking about
like where we were watching some movie
or something what's that by the way what
is that what is what that means like a
monogamous
marriage forever
we were watching a movie it was this
couple and i remember everybody being
like
everybody like that was dating like all
the kids like they were like children we
were 13 years old like partnered up and
everyone was just talking about in the
movie and everybody was watching it so
i'm telling you being like
this is not a reflection of my life or
my brain or who i am as a person
anyone's life
but yeah but you're told like right
especially straight kids get a lot of
like princess movies and disney
relationship movies and like there's no
one i mean statistically they're more
likely to get married than elders and
more likely to get divorced oh okay
but 51 of straight couples get divorced
yes because there's more than getting
married but like so the
the like i remember watching that and
just being like oh that's just not like
a a thing and then i just never how old
were you 2013. and you knew at that
point like this heterosexual
heteronormative thing is not going to
happen whatever you're telling me i was
like love relationship that's not for us
it's not going to happen
which is wrong it's incorrect but that's
right where my brain was just like
that's not happening and i just never
thought about it again what about new
information now where you see like maybe
just because of who you follow or
whatever i know it's not the same ratio
but do you see people in the lgbtq
community ia community sure and i
believe getting it and going like oh
that could happen for me no my brain
still goes that's not you it's every
time like my brain just it's like very
it's just stuck in that place i just
don't think about it is that a way to
protect yourself i don't know i don't
think about it because i mean we're
talking to devontisse and she was like i
just don't want to be with
people because i'm worried i'm going to
get rejected
yeah it's not just yeah us
sure we're you but i mean i don't know
my brain just always like that so i just
never i mean like that's why that's why
when people were always talking about
like do you think this person i mean i
just never i just don't think about that
i just that's what people like that's
why that's why i have a really big issue
when people come meet
lgbtq people they're always like this
guy's so hot and it's like that's one
that's a very weird thing to start a
conversation with and since women do
that to cis women i do that yeah you
know we all do women do that with each
other i do that as a way to connect with
people yeah i think in general so but i
mean
i just don't i never yeah but women do
that with women
it's like i'm saying in general
yeah yeah but is that so that do you
feel like you have a limiting belief
system there is a scientology are we
going into scientology no i can have
limiting belief systems you can be
defensive but there are women do that
with women too and men do that with men
about women totally yeah it's not just
an lgbtq thing no i think i'm talking
about women and men in general
i'm saying me i go to any fucking party
and it's like what do you think of him
you're like am i anything except someone
that needs to be set up with someone oh
i know but that's my thing is that i
when people do that to me my answer is
always like no i didn't mean to because
it's so it's just not because it's just
not on my right
and always very like shocking to people
like it's my only writer yeah yeah i'm
like people are always like very taken
aback by that they're always like oh and
they they can't think anything else to
talk about sure that's interesting i
mean that's what most people
you know that's their go to is he yeah
it's the weather the traffic lovely are
you single and can i set you up yeah
you know like the idea that people have
other things going on in their life
besides that is very like hard to
believe and i get i get it and i also
know that i don't put out the energy
because i've never been set up and
that's like people are very aware that i
am not
putting off the energy for that but you
can do it just for practice it doesn't i
think that that was the thing that that
changed my life the most it was like you
can go on dates with people and hang out
with people and it doesn't have to end
in marriage or heartbreak it can just be
right right and this is a new thing for
me at 39 years old i'm like going on
dates with people that i'm like
not like you're my husband or like i'm
going to fuck you in every lobby
let's just practice like it's just
practice i'd rather hang out with like a
friend
that is strange
being attracted to me is very
embarrassing to me
well what are you doing
to unpack that's not that's a whole
other thing that's not their fault i
mean who jokes about that all the time
on stand up well yeah that's something
we should bring up and better help
because that's it no doesn't bother me
because it's nothing bother me but if
someone's attracted to you like you
can't hate them or you're like charlie
chaplin where like i don't want to be a
part of any club that wants me like that
i do the same thing i now is someone
that has like fake boobs and like you
know wears makeup and knows how to wear
makeup and like when a guy's attracting
me i'm like oh you're like such a
fucking yeah honestly why are you
attracted to a woman with fake tits
i'll like someone unhinge and then
they'll like me and i'm like fucking
loser
literally yeah
yeah
yeah i'm like what's wrong with you
totally like yeah when someone like i
can see me yeah if someone's attracted
to me i'm like i want you to do a job
but what do you need just send me your
resume now and it says so much more
about us than them
and if someone's attracted to us and
we're disgusted by them because of that
that's on us
yeah because if they're not attract us
we're like ew you don't want a fucking
adult like you don't want this badass
bitch and then if they are no no
as soon as they're not attracted to me
i'm like i love you
i'm not anymore if someone's not
attracted to me at this point because
i've worked so hard to be like a
together person my bills are paid i'm
honest i'm like
yeah i have some stretch marks it's fine
you'll get through it like but if
someone's like not into me i'm like oh i
didn't see i went on a hinge date a
couple weeks ago
no i texted you
a guy named dustin oh yeah you did text
his dad for a safety test i remember
both of you he told his safety tax in
case anything happened to you his
picture and i was like i'm going on a
date with this guy to this japanese
restaurant just in case i don't kind of
work and you said don't get drunk
and uh well well sorry uh and so we went
on a date and there were just no like it
was mutually just which is fine which is
totally fine totally fine
if i never hear from and he treated like
i offered he treated i was like if i
never hear from this guy again i'm okay
like you drove yourself draw myself so
you already knew it wasn't and i was not
into it if you don't drive yourself you
already know it's not going to be but it
was a hint
it was a hinge date so i wasn't i wasn't
going to have him pick me up i would
never have an internet date you
shouldn't either you should never have
an app date picture
uh but it but then
but then the next day
he unmatched with me likes that we could
never communicate again and i was like i
need to protect his heart
no that's no that you know what that is
that's a little bit he loves you too
much
or he's just like i'm not gonna
waste energy on that i do that right
because he's not interested but as soon
as he wasn't you weren't either that's
what i'm saying but as soon as he wasn't
i was like oh like that's human nature
yeah that's a motherfucker you just have
to get ahead of that yeah i can do it
all the time i'm into this guy just
because he's not into me i know what
that is i also can't have pizza for
dinner every night i cannot keep putting
all the time well if he had reached out
again i would have been like how can i
get out of this i don't want to see him
again yeah that's just you wanting drama
though oh yeah like if you're able to go
on a date with somebody that's just you
wanting to join the bravo baby
this is why you come to this podcast you
know this is why you come to this
podcast for an older woman telling you
you're into somebody that's not into you
that's your adrenaline addiction and
that's your shit and you're wasting your
time and you're not building your
fucking million dollar business we do
think that maybe the guy that moved to
texas without telling me was too much in
love with me right nope he wasn't maybe
he had to move
so far follow him away maybe it'll be
different
so it'll be different this time we
wanted to be able
[Applause]
guys can get in touch with you anytime
whenever they want all the time
unless they lie i hate it as much as you
do
oh
jingle balls jingle bells i know you
guys hear a little bit of a zippy deed
in the zoo dot next to me and it's my
pacemaker it's uh uh benton's pacemaker
it is also the robot
that looks exactly like me that is uh
head is right next to me on the desk
next to a ton of beverages which is not
gonna go well
i my head just kind of hurts and i just
thought what's the point of having a
robot that can talk right that looks
like you if it can't help you with your
talking about student loans without
making yuck yucks because it's it's
serious business
if you've been thinking about
refinancing your student loans now is
the perfect time to check out earnest
federal loan payments are starting up
again on january 31st and interest rates
are historically low ernest makes it
easy but before you go for it review
cares act disclosures carefully
characteristic is the hash one student
number one it's the number one in the
country
they're in the top spot by helping
thousands of people get better rates
lower their monthly payments or by
helping their customers combine multiple
loans into a simple monthly payment
and ernest doesn't charge any fees ever
not even late fees
so
take two minutes yes it only takes two
minutes and see what your new rate could
be
don't worry there's no credit impact
i mean if you really refinance those
student loans maybe you can get a robot
i'm just saying that did save me a lot
of vocal stress ernest is offering our
listeners 100 cash bonus refinance your
student debt at earnest.com whitney not
available in all states once again you
get 100 cash bonus when you visit
earnest.com whitney to refinance your
student loans get to it visit
earnest.com whitney for more details not
available in all states terms and
conditions apply earnest student loan
refinancing made by earnest operations
llc nmls number not hash you dumb robot
number one two oh four nine one seven
california refinancing law that was
dicey license number 605 4788 535
mission street san francisco california
nine for 105 visit earnest.com licenses
for a full list of licenses and now that
we have a sex robot in here with us
let's talk about sex because her vagina
is dry
and she needs to lube up um
if you're having trouble getting your
sex robot wet
we can help you
uh okay
phoria uh this phoria now in addition to
having the um the really cuticle bottles
of the cbd oil that is a game changer um
has these suppositories that you can put
in 20 minutes before and i melt inside
you
and benton even if you're cold-blooded
like me they'll still melt and benton
busted me having them in my bag
yeah on my tour
hi again
i found these uh phoria suppository with
cbd can you find them or did i say hey
we need to i found them okay nothing's
planned here trust me
and i just want to know what you plan on
doing with these
well on tour
unless you plan on popping one in and
sliding down the hallway like a fucking
slug later to give me a bag of crispy
chips this is inappropriate
look i just being around you all the
time really dries me up
and i i'm sure that's not
just being weathered there was a guy at
the show tonight that told me i'm his
hall pass
and i
was like do i have a say in this and
he's like no no he said ma'am you need a
hall pass to be out here
because i'm so young looking no because
the nursing home makes you have a home
[Laughter]
wow that was beautiful so who is fouria
floria is using all natural and
plant-based ingredients to intensify
sexual pleasure and relieve discomfort
didn't you see how comfortable we were
in that video too
phoria has a serious cult following with
tens of thousands of people who have had
their sex lives transformed through
using their products and i know that
whitney's my life was my sex life was
transformed i'll never have it again
everyone's life has been transported
with an actual person why bother if you
have phoria in your pant awakening
arousal oil uses cbd and warming
sensations
best of all awaken just turns you
on you even turned one before uh try
this let's go you know me i fully
endorse you to treat yourself to more
deeper fully
it's the holidays you guys gotta start
masturbating having sex with somebody
anyone use phoria you deserve it it's
offering a special deal for what has
come
if y'all weren't aroused already get
twenty percent off your first order by
visiting fourier wellness slash whitney
or use code whitney at checkout that's f
o r i a
wellness dot com forward slash whitney
for twenty percent off your first order
i recommend trying they're awakened
arousal oil and sex oil you will thank
me later also the support stories we
were gonna i was gonna show them but i
think we're out
i'm gonna get this for my daughter stop
it now back to more of us
by the way back to more of this arousing
intercourse conversation yeah have more
intercourse with us oh yeah oh my god
but what are your goals do you want a
partner next year yes no maybe
uh the right partner i mean i just want
a partner sure
for sure a partner no
yeah
i do believe there is nothing that i
have not explicitly asked for while
willist being embarrassed that i've not
gotten yeah
if you want something now's the time to
ask for it okay can you ask the podcast
subscribe to us
yeah what do you want i don't i don't
like it when people want something and
can't articulate it because you're not
going to get it and now i'm involved
are you asking me i say this all the
time i'm like do you guys want to be on
camera do you want to be writers do you
want to have your own show just you have
to say it out loud if you want it if you
don't say it out loud and you don't get
it
are you asking me specific are you just
in general i'm just saying anyone
listening you want a robot
that is narcoleptic ask for it she we
put her to sleep hours ago
if you want to be in if you want a to be
married fine like my thing is it doesn't
matter what you're asking for i'm not
going to judge you but you do have to be
able to say it out loud yeah if you
can't know
if you can't say it out loud you're not
going to get it right that's the that is
the one thing i don't know i'm sorry
that you do know so one thing i don't
know if there's an opinion i don't know
if there's anything i know it's that if
you do not explicitly ask for what you
want right in a word document in a
journal out loud it doesn't have to be
on this podcast you are not going to get
it you know what so sometimes i know how
true that is that i'm afraid to
articulate sure because i'm like i need
a beat i mean
i'm old enough now where i don't need
anything i need a bunch of beats do you
guys have any beats but i'm saying like
i know how true that is that i'm like
waiting to be able to articulate it
perfectly because i know whatever i'm
not making a wish to a genie well you
you kind of are
someone so do you want to be married or
not next year is the question for us if
i meet the right person i'd want to
marry
i would say not be married just be in a
relationship with some someone that's
fulfilling that's easy right and when
you sign it you will sign up
i would like no energy put towards that
from either
prenup and you will be i think getting
married is a bad goal i think saying
like
i want to be with what everyone should
get a prenup no i i mean my everyone
should get a prenup yeah i'm keeping all
my ravioli chef boyardee
not getting a prenup prenup has nothing
to do with love it's just about actually
if you bring up a prenup and they're not
into it that's a fucking red flag if you
want to go like hey we both leave with
what we brought if you have a hundred
thousand dollars in your bank account
right now yeah and you marry someone
right and then they cheat on you in a
year yeah they don't you should have
that hundred thousand dollars yes
thousand percent because i agree with
that a hundred thousand hundred percent
so that's what a prenup is and a hundred
thousand more for being cheated on yes
if i
i'm very appropriate and whatever you
make so the thing is in a lot of a lot
of um places so if you and i get married
tomorrow emily
i know
imagine and then you go write a script
and i'm with you every day and i'm kind
of like having sex with you when you're
writing it like taking care of you
giving you grilled cheese and then you
can make a billion dollars fixing your
printer i can go to court and go hey all
that
money that she made exactly
writing this script i deserve some of
because i was emotional support
maybe that's true yeah i don't fucking
know but as someone that has written a
lot of scripts emotional support is a
fucking hassle and it has not been why
i've made anything i've made things in
spite of emotional support yeah and it's
someone that's kind of just trying to
take something that you have right just
sign a prenup exactly what's up if you
really love each other why can't you
just sign one yeah and go hey we're
never gonna break up let's fucking sign
this it'll be so fun let's get drunk and
sign this thing
and we never have to think about it
again i have no problemo with prenatal
watch succession
even if you have no money sign a prenup
because you will at some point that's my
goal for everybody so next year your
goal is a premium
that's it i don't need the partner it's
just the prenatal sound yourself what do
you want next year
next year i want to shoot a special that
i'm really proud of that i don't have
that i don't compromise on okay do you
feel like you compromise on the last one
i i i think if you
are like really into what you do
creatively you never feel like it you
were good enough at it right right 100
percent you know what i'm saying right i
could have tried harder could have been
better or could have written more could
have like i'm always in editing thinking
of tags for any special person so you're
shooting a special you're getting
married and i'm being left no i'm not
getting married that is not my goal i
would like to shoot a special i love
i would like to maybe find a a child to
adopt
somewhere
besides youtube
i mean i could be from appalachia i'm a
very dead people
i i do want i would like at some point
to adopt a child that needs does the
child know home
they will run away many times i will run
to my home
big run i i see myself adopting a child
that's in foster care or something
um i am not going to get pregnant until
next september if i do i don't believe
in deadlines adopting a kid and getting
pregnant yeah yeah a lot of people i
know have uh we're starting an orphanage
yeah a lot of people i know have adopted
and then because they weren't thinking
about trying to get pregnant anymore
then got pregnant yeah and they now have
like two kids three months yeah wild
happens very often because when you're
trying so hard to have a kid sometimes
you shut down your own your body won't
do it yeah because you're producing so
much cortisol that your body goes like
gorillas
correct which is the sad irony of all
the celebrities that are visiting rwanda
and they're like the gorillas aren't
mating it's because you're there bitch
because you're looking at them please
leave no one they're not starving don't
want to fuck in front of celebrities
that's awkward to them they know you're
join our only fans um
i think other than that i want to
uh
make the tour happen we have like
i know but i'm saying 30 more cities
yeah i'm just saying i want to like nail
it hit it out of the park not phone in
one show and would this special be after
the tour no it's probably going to be
it's going to be like march
and then i'll i'll do the same stuff
another couple months and then the but
it'll be fine because i won't have air
yet right right right um and i want to
like rescue more horses and dogs and if
a man comes along that can handle my
life and how big it is and how many
other people i have in my life um
filling my needs not sexually but
emotionally right applause godspeed
you're welcome if you can
cherry on top yeah if you can like
handle that's a good dragon the fact
that there's like five people in my home
at all times that i think are funnier
than you
you're welcome to come in here
and fucking fuck me every now and then
i just it's like i do think though that
like i'm trying to kind of go back to
the model of like
you're supposed to have a bunch of
girlfriends
and then a man
that
comes in every now and then yeah i'm
watching that brothel i get it
i get mad men
yeah i i want my daughter i'm a madman
bitch yeah you know what i'm saying yeah
i want a husband who cheats on me no i
don't want to like i just feel like men
like this whole thing where men and
women are supposed to like be besties i
just am like surrendering to a little
bit it's like i want to try to get my
emotional needs met through my
girlfriends my dogs myself and then
whatever a man has the bandwidth for i
would like to show up for that but i
know that a lot of men
have a limited amount of bandwidth for
like
hot goss
because the kind of man i want is very
alpha
and he might not want to talk about like
emma's a wolf yeah sure
frankly whitney would love to do she
would love to dance
is to like go this is the kind of man i
want and then not go but i need you to
be like also my best girlfriend and also
my psychiatrist and also my psychic and
also my all this other like if i you
know every time you do this the robot
goes
no i'm gonna surrender
to your nature because i would want a
man to surrender to my nature or whoever
i date yeah you know what i'm saying
does that make sense a thousand percent
it's not like i want this guy it's like
i want someone that is okay with
me and i'm okay with them yes and we
both get our needs met in a healthy way
that's hopefully legal yeah and we're
not constantly going like i need more
from you right you can't provide right
that's the dream right or to just need
less
yeah because happiness is an inside job
weird because all my problems are on the
outside
but how you handle them is on the inside
and that's what me oh jesus christ all
right well i your best and
betterhelp.org um can we wrap up by
reading the poem
oh that's so fun a good for you fan
wrote a poem is this slow a tree i'm
going to say one thing about poetry
which is that i had a poem in a book in
general
in general i don't think poetry is real
i don't either i don't think acting is
really there yeah maya angelou okay this
is a good for you palm by katarina wait
who's reading it okay well how about you
i can tell you want to because i do i
love poetry
because i myself am a poem okay listen
with
you can't type and listen yep yeah i
actually can
there's a lot we know that stuff we know
it's a possibility i actually the data
we have anything i've ever made i was
typing and listening
um
there's a lot of other things i should
probably do but instead i write about
good for you the podcast that consumes
my life the simple joys of a housewife
whitney is the ultimate alpha female
brains in beauty the perfect cocktail
she hosts deeply psychological
conversations as well as deep throating
demonstrations
she
she makes me laugh she makes me cry she
tells me which grape seed oil to apply
oh
wait can you scroll down jesus christ
which is the cheapest one whitney told
me to stop saying sorry now my husband
is starting to worry she shares all her
insights from her recovery that lead her
to self-discovery oh come on from
inherited family trauma to all her
boyfriend drama don't give her an edible
or the outcome will be incredible
or the outcome will be incredible from
blacking out and pissing in a bush to
bombing a zoom call from too much kush
wow she often thinks she's in a
simulation drinking june china it's not
a negotiation
she dated that seems like destiny turns
out cougars aren't his specialty
the good for you crew
that's brutal the good for you crew is
part of the match
the good for you crew is part of the
magic the chaos between them is
beautifully tragic benton is an icon
legend and star his childhood stories
are absolutely bizarre emily is always
dressed like a mime nothing's more
embarrassing than when she tried to rock
climb
grace is the youngest we're three years
apart of all the blokes she always
trying to keep them all woke the best
podcast to ever exist it'll grow on you
like a benign cyst
i had mine removed yesterday i watch the
videos every thursday makes me feel like
it's my motherfucking birthday
merry christmas to the whole damn crew
you better read this on the christmas
special or fuck you
who is this what is this
her name's katarina katarina yeah okay
is she russian uh her last name is can
we say her last name
okay
katarina buick in awe and slightly
terrified of you well done thank you
and you've now made it so that none of
us can ever make eye contact again and i
appreciate that
um oh my that's really nice i know that
was right the nicest part of the whole
thing oh my god it's very on
point yep everyone gets death i feel
like i'm not getting away with what i
thought i was getting away with and i
am i'm not wearing stripes
was great
that you know what when people know
everything about the podcast it really
warms my heart it really does yeah
because i'm like oh like all like this
and we didn't even show the rock
climbing video on the podcast
and you weren't rock climbing
i was flopping around on a map yeah
it is very weird it's like when i
started doing a podcast i was like i
have no idea what this is going to be
why would anyone but people
we need a in the new year we're going to
keep doing them keep doing this i think
you know what
i think we i think we're going to do a
podcast i think we might next year hit
our stride what was that i was just
associating yeah no
let's
ask for ideas like did you guys look
through the emails did people have ideas
on what they want
like things they want to see in 2022 no
the only consistent thing to ask for
send emails what do you like
through the comments no no but we
haven't specifically asked that's a good
thing to ask the fans so i'm big on
feedback i'm big on focus groups so
leave us a voicemail 818-538-9940
or email us good for you fans at
gmail.com tell us about dick pics no
tell us what you want to see more of
okay what do you like what kind of game
what kind of cakes should we sit on what
what kind of wedgies do you want how
much more burping do you want to hear
what kind of bras right less clothes
more clothes what is i have to have more
clothes what is making you tune in or
out what makes you hard oh then we
should we leave no
no we should stay
[Laughter]
i know sis i mean this is out whatever i
am is very out right now the riddler i
think he's back in
the batman
guys merry christmas we love you happy
holidays don't forget oh my god emily
merry christmas
today them and all the others happy
holidays winter solstice happy kwanzaa
happy hanukkah even though it's over no
these are all the winter holidays oh my
god okay i now name all the genders go
their gender doesn't exist hanukkah
you've just ended nailed it
we are always taking feedback for what
you want to see in 2022 i'm going to
spend a bunch of time i might even do
ayahuasca sitting down seeing what you
want for the next chapter we will film
of this podcast because we are changing
the podcast studio it is going to be
refurbished and entirely all the fan art
that y'all sent is going to be in
cabinets and in bookcases behind us
yes and we are going to love it
this is the point in a tv show when you
go okay let's get feedback let's course
correct and let's do what the fans want
so now's the time to send us emails
voicemails is this season two uh
no this is season three i mean this is a
i mean in network television this would
be syndicated by now and we would have
given up but we're doing the opposite
we're going to lean in and try harder
and and not give up at all
never uh and start you know just one
season we'll never quit
[Laughter]
a good night
don't ride reindeer
[Music]
[Applause]